last year the NH has turned 70 and
enjoyed a 20 billion pound birthday
present from the prime minister now they
have to work out what they're going to
do with it because many believe the NHS
needs some radical change if it's to
deliver world leading health care into
the next decade the government's amount
about to publish its 10-year plan for
the NHS so we're joined now by the
Health and Social Care secretary live
from the West Suffolk hospital Matt
Hancock thank you for being with us
today good morning how are you not too
bad I hope you're well as well so tell
us what is in this plan well as you say
the twenty billion pounds extra that
we're putting into the NHS over the next
five years is there to make sure it's
sustainable for the long term but money
alone is not enough we need to see a big
shift in the way that health services
are delivered so that essentially we
focus on prevention as much as we do on
cure of course the hospitals like this
do an amazing job in helping people to
get better when they're ill but
increasingly over the last generation
the focus needs to be on making sure
that we support people in the community
that we support people through for
instance through GPS and that we ask
people as well as giving them rights for
free care free at the point of use we
also ask them to take responsibility to
keep the pressure off the NHS and and
make sure that it's there for people who
really need it I mean some people in the
Conservative Party will think this
sounds bit like a nanny state oh I don't
think so at all asking people to take
personal responsibility is the very
opposite of that we then need to empower
them to do so so for instance the the
ability to go and see your GP or to have
support in the community even for
somebody who's very frail to be given
the money to be able to makes a
improvements to your home so that you
don't trip so that you don't end up in
this emergency department which is very
expensive for the NHS as well as
obviously very bad for the patient
making sure that we can help people
to stay healthy is that the core of what
a national health service should be
doing and you know the the focus just on
what happens in in hospitals and means
that we don't spend enough for effort
and resources both government resources
but also asking people to take
responsibility themselves to keep people
healthy the whole purpose of the NHS
over the next 10 years needs to shift
towards helping people to stay healthy
as much as curing them when they're ill
you've got a bit of a problem they
haven't you and that's about stuff
because currently there is a hundred
thousand vacancies in the NHS I just
want to talk you through some of the
numbers because I'll be honest I was
pretty shocked when I was doing the
research for this interview forty-one
thousand unfilled nursing posts six
thousand GP short of the number that we
need three thousand midwives short I
mean your ten-year plan isn't going to
work if you haven't got the people to
implement it well of course when you put
20 billion pounds into something we're
going to need the people to deliver
absolutely right and the plan has a
detailed workforce chapter and then
there's going to be further work on
making sure that we have the people that
we need we need to recruit more we need
to train more and also we need to retain
the people in the NHS who are working so
hard now taking the pressure off them
actually is one of the important things
we can do to retain how will you do that
well let's take the nurses figure that
you gave 41,000 our vacancies you
mentioned actually 30,000 of those
vacancies are currently filled but
they're filled by people working through
for instance agencies rather than
full-time that could be fixed we've also
got to have more because that still
doesn't bring us up to the full
complement and so we're expanding
training we've got a an expansion of the
training budgets we've got we're going
to make sure that we also recruit better
and we've got to make sure as I say that
we retain those who are currently
working in the NHS and a lot of that
means taking taking the pressure off
as if it's all under control but
actually on the ground if you talk to
people or you get a very different
picture I mean I was speaking to someone
for example who works in a rural GP
practitioner and they were saying that
in the last year they've advertised for
a nurse practitioner a practice nurse
and the GP and receive zero applicants
and that is not an isolated case I mean
this is a crisis isn't it a crisis where
you're not had you haven't got enough
people who are working in the health
service well this is why we've got a
long-term plan and in fact we have we
said before that we thought of the
twenty billion three and a half billion
pounds needed to go to primary care and
community care in fact we're going to be
putting four and a half billion pounds
extra into primary care and community
care and yes that means we're going to
need a lot more community nurses we're
going to need more GPS as you say we've
got a target for more GPS and this is
all part of the plan
to make sure that we have people near a
big picture here if you step back we
have a population that is ageing and
also getting wealthier and there's
populations get wealthier and as they
age they need more health care and that
means that we need more people focused
on on health care in keeping people
healthy so that requires that requires
training it also requires recruitment
and part of the plan is to solve exactly
the sorts of issues that you were
talking about and exactly the sorts of
shortages that you mentioned from from
talking to the people who you did you're
talking about the challenges of an aging
population and of course one of the big
challenges facing the NHS in social care
but I can't found anything on social
care in this plan that in the brief that
we've been given and so can you tell me
when the green paper is going to be
finally published on it yes we're gonna
have a green paper on social care soon
the plan does actually cover the very
important the very important links
between health and social care because
there's the the the the link between
making sure you can get people out of
hospital when they don't need to be in
hospital but they do need care that
that's critical it will be wandering in
in in the coming weeks there's a clearly
you know there's a big focus on one
other big subject as well in Parliament
at the moment but we've the plan is the
green paper is well developed and it
fits with and goes alongside this
long-term plan for the NHS and the other
part of the plan that I know that you're
very passionate about is technology and
you're talking about targeting people
with unhealthy habits for example people
who enjoy smoking enjoy drinking for
example with targeted adverts a bit like
politicians do during election campaigns
so does that mean that medical data will
be become available to private companies
no doesn't mean that at all what what we
propose there is that as part of this
this approach to try to keep support
people to stay healthy in the past
public health messages have tended just
to go to the population as a whole
you know we all know the mantra that you
should eat five a day that is a public
health message and it's normally we give
the same message right across the
population increasingly with new
technology actually you can better
target those messages so instead of
saying to everybody the same thing you
can you can say for instance if you are
a smoker and that is very bad for your
health but if you're a smoker and you're
pregnant then that's not only bad for
your health but seriously bad for your
baby's health and we can target messages
at people to try to make sure that they
maintain healthier lifestyles instead of
you know what I don't like in in this
area is punishing the masses for the
problems that only a minority have take
alcohol for example and a fifth of
people drink a third of all the out a
five percent of people drink a third of
all the alcohol in the country five
percent
and yet many of us you know like a nice
pint and it's perfectly healthy so I
think instead of things like minimum
unit pricing that some people suggests
we should target measures so that if
it's somebody who has a serious drinking
problem that leads them to end up using
the NHS in a hospital like this then
they should get much more active
intervention and counseling to try to
support them so that we're not stopping
the most people from having a perfectly
healthy drink or punishing them and
instead we're tackling the problem where
it really is serious now brexit of
course affects all government Apartments
at the minute and a lot of people very
worries that if there is no deal
and there'll be shortages of medicine so
can you as health secretary guarantee
now that even if there is a deal that no
deal can be reached people will be able
to get the medicine that they need yes
we are confident that if everybody does
what they need to do then we'll have an
unhindered supply of medicines and
obviously this is very very important in
all brexit scenarios no matter what
happens in those negotiations people
should be able to get their supplies
there's an awful lot of work going on to
ensure that that's the case and we're
confident that you know that so long as
everybody needs does what they need to
do because a lot of this relies on the
pharmaceutical companies and others so
it isn't entirely in the gift of the the
government but we need to do what we
need to do and the pharmaceutical
industry so far that work has been
progressing very well I've been very
pleased with the response of the
pharmaceutical industry who obviously
take this incredibly seriously and you
know frankly a hospital should be get
the the supply of drugs in exactly the
same way as they do now you know they
shouldn't notice any different because
the the unhindered supply should be done
within the pharmaceutical supply chain
and we've got plans underway to make
sure that that can happen in confidence
that something will happen isn't the
same as a guarantee there is
well the truth is that in medical
supplies there are these sorts of
shortages all the time in the autumn
there was a shortage of epi pens because
of a problem with supply at the factory
in America where they were made so
actually the NHS and the department deal
with these sorts of these sorts of
issues all of the time so that's why I
used the language that I do because
there's there's always all sorts of
problems I mean frankly one of the jobs
of the health secretary is to prepare
for all sorts of things that you don't
want to happen but but do happen you
know we have people at the moment out in
the Democratic Republic of Congo dealing
with Ebola I don't want a bowler to be a
problem but I'm absolutely happy to
ensure that we put resources into
stopping it and so the this sort of
planning happens all of the time and
we're clear that we're not going to over
promise but we are confident that the
plans are in place and that as long as
everybody does what they need to do then
there'll be the unhindered supply of
medicines in whatever the brexit
scenario okay now it was reported in
November that you told cabinet that you
couldn't guarantee that people wouldn't
die as a result of a No Deal brexit now
I'm not asking you to go into
confidential cabinet discussions I know
you don't want to do that but can you
guarantee that people's lives will be
safe I'm confident that we'll have the
unhindered supply of medicines so long
as the plans that we have in place are
properly enacted I didn't actually say
what you reported to cabinet and I'm
really I'm really very clear on the on
the position here which is that there's
a lot of work to do to make sure that we
get to that position
some of it's for government and we are
doing that I now have a you know a whole
floor of my department working on this
and we've put money behind it already as
has been widely reported making sure
that there's facilities so that we've
got the stockpiles of drugs that we need
but I'm also not going to over promise
I'm doing everything that we that we
that we need to and everything that we
can to make sure that there's the
unhindered supply no matter what happens
okay
and very briefly the Prime Minister is
going to be putting her brexit D lad
back for a parliamentary votes shortly
we believe in the next fortnight or so
do you think anyone's change their minds
out of Christmas well I certainly hope
that the chances of the the deal going
through have improved I think if people
have gone back to their constituent
Caesars I have and I talk to normal
people then they will have found a
overwhelming sense of just please can we
get on with it and the plan on the table
is the best plan it will get rid of all
the problems we've just been talking
about in terms of No Deal
and it will also mean that we have both
a close economic relationship with the
EU in the future and deliver on the
referendum result I think it's
overwhelming the the best way forward
compared to either No Deal or a second
referendum which would be divisive
hugely divisive but it wouldn't be
decisive because people would say well
why not have the best of three so I'm
I'm just I'm very confident that the
plan is the best way forward and I very
much hope that on listening to to
constituents and taking a bit of time to
consider the questions over over
Christmas people come back the plan that
gets on and delivers brexit and delivers
brexit in a way that means that our
economy can thrive we can then support
our public services like the NHS and
there's a great bright future out there
for this country and we need to get on
with building it